vamos a realizar un par de problemas más
sobre fuerza y momentos vamos a dibujar
nuestro sube y baja
no tenemos aquí
nuestro
punto de apoyo nuestro pivote está acá y
vamos a tener varias fuerzas que están
distribuidas en ambos lados de este sube
y baja tenemos aquí un hacia arriba una
fuerza de 10 minutos y se encuentra a
una distancia del punto de pivote de 10
metros
vamos a tener otra fuerza aquí pero este
va a ser hacia abajo es una buena no tan
chico verdad es de una fuerza
hacia abajo no hacia la hacia abajo esta
va a ser una fuerza bastante grande de
50 newtons y va a estar a una distancia
de 8 metros y vamos a tener otra fuerza
esta va a ir hacia arriba es de 5
newtons y está a una distancia de 4
metros
y de este lado tenemos una fuerza hacia
arriba de 10 minutos y está a una
distancia de mi punto de pivote de 3
metros tengo otra fuerza hacia abajo
bueno
tratando de hacerlo hacia abajo y ahora
sí de 20 minutos
su distancia es de 8 metros metros estos
momentos y tenemos aquí nuestra fuerza
misteriosa y bueno vamos en este momento
a asumir que va hacia arriba y esta
fuerza quiero calcular cuál debe ser o
qué cantidad debe haber aquí para que
toda esta este sube y baja se mantenga
sin rotar es decir que todas las los
momentos que vayan en sentido horario
sean iguales a todos los momentos que
van en sentido antihorario
entonces vamos a resaltar en diferente
color cuáles son los momentos que van en
sentido horario bueno éste vemos que
tiende ahí es en sentido horario como
las manecillas del reloj entonces vamos
a resaltarlo
esto va en sentido horario que éste no
esté también
ahora de este otro lado este no va en
sentido horario éste sí va
y bueno nuestra fuerza misteriosa que
estamos asumiendo que va en sentido
antihorario entonces ahora las fuerzas
que quedan las vamos a resaltar
en otro color y con otra forma para
ubicar cuáles son las fuerzas que tengo
que estar sumando y compensando entonces
si queremos calcular
todos bueno cuál es nuestra fuerza
misteriosa bueno tenemos que todos los
momentos en sentido horario que son
estos voy a ponerlos para acá 10
voy a calcular el momento es la fuerza
por la distancia del brazo y pívot diez
minutos por diez metros más
5 newtons por 4 metros
aquí estoy mezclando con unidades y sin
unidades
es 20 minutos por 8 metros esto debe ser
igual
voy a poner en otro color las que van en
sentido antihorario que son
50 minutos por 8 metros más
8 metros
para un 20 minutos por 8 metros si estoy
bien no no estoy bien ok
son las que están resaltadas con este
color entonces es 10 newtons por 3
metros 10 por 3
más nuestra fuerza misteriosa que es me
pasó decirles que esta fuerza misteriosa
está ubicada a 10 metros de distancia
entonces vamos a calcular esto 10 x 10
ahora 100 5 por 4 son 20 20 por 8 son
160 y esto debe ser igual a
50 por 8 400
más 30 más 10 efe
nos queda sumamos estos son 280
que es igual a
430 más 10 f
estos 430 nos pasamos restando entonces
son 280 m2
menos
430 igual a 10 efe
y aquí nos quedan menos 150 igual a 10
efe y finalmente me queda f igual a
menos 15 minutos
esta fuerza salió menos 15 newtons
quiere decir que en realidad de esta
fuerza va en sentido
horario esta fuerza es de 15 newtons
aquí hacia abajo para compensar todas
las demás fuerzas y que se mantenga en
equilibrio este sube y baja yo espero
que con este problema haya sido menos
con su uso que el anterior ahora vamos a
resolver otro problema y este es un tipo
de problemas que solían confundirme la
primera vez que aprendí sobre momentos
pero en cierta manera son de los
problemas más útiles
voy a dibujar aquí abajo para aprovechar
el espacio en otro color supongamos
que tengo aquí una mesa
vista del lado
tengo aquí la tabla
y aquí tengo dos patas es una mesa
especial que nada más tiene dos patas en
lugar de cuatro
seguramente son patas muy largas muy
anchos que pueden soportar esta tabla
voy a tener mi centro de masa de la mesa
aquí
está en este punto de masa en este
centro de masa se tiene una fuerza
hacia abajo de 20 minutos
y además encima de la mesa he puesto una
caja de libros
bastante pesada
está
ejerce esta caja una fuerza
hacia abajo de 100 newtons
y bueno lo que quiero calcular es cuánto
peso soporta cada una de las patas de la
mesa
bueno este puedes no parecer un problema
de momentos obvios pero en unos momentos
verán que si es como vamos a calcular
esto bueno conocemos que ambas patas
están soportando la mesa y cualquiera
que sea la fuerza que la mesa ejercía
abajo las patas van a ejercer la misma
fuerza hacia arriba así que la cantidad
de fuerza que cada una de las patas
ejerce bueno compensa lo que el peso que
va hacia abajo así que lo que vamos a
hacer es escoger una pata de manera
arbitraria pues se me ocurre que podemos
elegir
esta pata de la mesa y también tenemos
que elegir arbitrariamente un eje de
rotación yo voy a elegir el eje de
rotación acá y por qué elegí este punto
bueno porque piensen que sí esta pata
comenzará a empujar más de lo debido o
tuviera más fuerza toda la mesa estaría
rotando el sentido antihorario
y lo mismo si este mes se volviera de
repente muy débil pues ya no podría
sostener toda la mesa entonces
comenzarían a caer y a moverse oa rotar
en sentido horario ya suponiendo que
esta otra pata sigue haciendo su trabajo
y no se va se va a mover a ningún lado
una vez que establecemos esto entonces
podemos tratarlo ahora así como un
problema de momento
si esta pata elegida no existiera
entonces toda la mesa giraría en sentido
horario por lo que esta pata debe estar
ejerciendo un momento en sentido
antihorario para mantener la mesa fija
así que tengo aquí
hay que no tengo buen pulso el día de
hoy ustedes disculpen una fuerza hacia
arriba y vamos a llamar la fuerza de la
pata afp
y cuál va a ser esta fuerza de la pata
bueno algo que debe indicar antes son
las distancias que hay
es la distancia
que hay este de este punto
el centro bueno a esta parte de la caja
de libros a esta parte de donde se está
creciendo el peso esta distancia de aquí
acá
es de 1 metro
la distancia de este punto hacia el
centro de masa es de 2 metros
y de la misma manera el punto o la
distancia de este centro de masa hasta
esta otra parte son 2 metros
bueno ahora si podemos resolver esto
como un problema de momentos ya que
estamos teniendo pues nuestras fuerzas
nuestro eje de rotación y las distancias
recuerda que todos los momentos en
sentido horario tienen que ser iguales a
los momentos en sentido antihorario la
pata elegida es lo único que evita que
toda la mesa rote en sentido horario así
que todas las demás fuerzas o momentos
van a ir en sentido horario así que
tengo bueno este primer elemento que son
y bueno mi masa bueno la fuerza que se
quede es x son 100 newtons por un metro
más
y esta fuerza de aquí que es de 20
newtons
por 2 metros con esto voy a calcular los
momentos
y esto debe ser igual a la fuerza de la
pata
multiplicado por la distancia de este
punto de rotación o de este eje hasta
acá que vienen siendo 4 metros x 4
la pata izquierda también está que si no
una fuerza pero como su distancia al eje
de rotación es cero aquí no está
ocurriendo en ningún momento por eso es
que no lo tomamos en cuenta con estos
cálculos
así que bueno vamos a resolver tenemos
aquí 100 más 40 es igual a 4 fuerza de
la pata
140 es igual a 4 fuerza de la pata y la
fuerza en la pata va a resultar igual a
140 entre
435 newtons hacia arriba esta fuerza va
a ser igual a 35 minutos ya encontramos
está bueno ahora quiero saber cuál es la
fuerza que soporta esta otra pata para
esto necesitamos conocer la fuerza total
ejercida bueno tenemos que la fuerza
hacia abajo de estos elementos el total
de esta fuerza es de
120 entonces tenemos que la fuerza de la
pata
esta que acabamos de encontrar más la
fuerza de la pata 2
debe ser igual a 120 newtons así que
bueno ya encontré este valor es 35 más
la fuerza de la pata 2 igual a 120
la fuerza de la pata 2 va a ser igual a
120 menos 35
y nos va a resultar en 85 minutos
también esta fuerza es hacia arriba
y esta fuerza de la pata 2 es igual a 85
minutos
bueno esto lo estamos que no se está
moviendo sabemos que la fuerza ejercida
es son estos valores para mantener el
equilibrio y bueno nos ustedes se pueden
dar cuenta que este esta pata 2 está
soportando un peso una fuerza mayor que
la pata de la derecha pues por qué
porque el peso o la caja de libros que
es lo que está aportando la mayor
cantidad de peso está más cerca de esta
pata que de esta otra si esta caja
estuviera en medio ambas patas estarían
soportando la misma cantidad de fuerza y
este tipo de problemas son clave para la
construcción de puentes o muebles o en
ingeniería civil y arquitectura porque
se tiene que calcular el diseño cuánto
peso puede soportar cada una de las
estructuras de apoyo espero que hayan
comprendido esto y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo